the family of a black teenager in
Wisconsin is considering legal action
after the teen was handcuffed over an
apparent false robbery call Wauwatosa
Police Department cameras captured
Sunday's incident Akhil Carter was
riding in a car with his white
grandmother police say they pulled the
car over after getting a tip that two
black males were robbing a white woman
nearby shel Miller shows why the
family's attorney is questioning the
story from the police Michelle good
morning good morning they are indeed a
police spokesperson says the officers
responded appropriately and released the
teen as soon as they realized there was
a misunderstanding
still the family wonders how this
potentially dangerous situation could
have happened in the first place after
ordering 18 year-old Akhil Carter out of
his grandmother's car hands up on the
air police placed him in handcuffs and
ordered him into the back of a squad car
grandmother paulette bar had just left
church and was driving a kill to work
when police stopped them officers say
they initially started following them
after an african-american man and woman
identified the vehicle they said it was
carrying a white woman who was being
robbed by two black men but police say
they never got a formal statement from
those witnesses because they left the
area the family's attorney is skeptical
it seems strange that for all the
dashcam footage the police have turned
over we have not seen anything where the
officers interacting with these people
after Carter was detained an officer is
seen exiting the patrol car with his gun
outside the holster officers then
approached the teens grandmother
[Music]
police say Carter was handcuffed for
approximately six minutes I'm guessing
what this sounds like is we would be
misunderstanding after the teen was
released a witness captured his
grandmother's reaction so grandson Wow
the family's attorney says even if the
police account is accurate
the officers clearly overreacted any
random person can run up to a police
officer now and say stop that car it's
engaged in a robbery and that's all it
takes the family's attorney says the
frightening encounter left the
grandmother feeling helpless wondering
what she could have done to protect her
grandson yeah a lot of questions there
Michelle Miller thank you a lot of
people winning that's your grandson Wow
hi what what is this all about a lot of
questions Thank You Michelle